Welcome back to another episode of
What's Up Prof.
Hello Walter. Hi Martin.
Are you doing well?
Martin, the question has been repetitive
over more than two years and the answer
is always yes, even if it's not.
Well,
you know, it depends on what we mean,
like we've mentioned before with are you
well? Yes, if you ask someone how are
you and they answer you want the long
version or the short version, then you
know you're in trouble.
And then you have to be honest.
Do you actually want to know or do you
are you just asking because it's a
rhetorical question? It's a common
courtesy. That's it.
Well,
let's open with a word of prayer and
let's get started.
Our heavenly Father, thank you. Thank
you for giving us the blessing of doing
these discussions.
We ask that you enlighten our minds,
also the viewers and listeners
and that you give us the Holy Spirit
to guide us. In Jesus' name, amen. Amen.
You know Martin, I find it so
interesting
that
we're living in a time
when it seems as if
for the first time really
everything is coming together and the
Lord really, really could be coming very
soon, right?
Why does nobody want it?
I think
there's a few answers to that probably.
Scared.
But even those that you would expect it
that they would love to hear news like
that.
When you say that the time is short,
very short
or if you dare say when the 6,000 should
be up more or less
then
they all freak.
What is the problem? Don't they want to
go home?
I wish everybody would get that longing
to go home. I think
blessed hope? Isn't it the glorious
appearing of our Lord? Yes, but I think
people are too caught up in the worldly
things.
Even if it's not um looking for it, but
you're so busy or
time just runs away.
I mean just now recently again I heard
numerous times, not in my lifetime.
Yeah. Why? Why? Why would somebody
answer like that?
Why would somebody answer like that? So
what is the advent hope and eternal
life?
It's actually two things here, right?
The advent hope is the coming of Christ
but it leads then to eternal life for
those that have chosen
the right path, right? Correct. The
narrow path actually. So it's very
important that you link the requirements
for eternal life to the advent hope
because what's the point of hoping
if there's no eternal life attached to
it, right?
True. Aren't you
um supposed to prepare for eternal life
through the advent hope that you have?
Yes, well, you're hoping for the advent
hope to take place so that eternal life
can become a reality. But you can't live
your life now if you're looking forward
to the eternal life, now you're living
it as a hooligan.
If you want to put it that way.
Like a Halloweenigan.
Yes.
No, that's not going to work. And it's
actually ridiculous if you think we are
looking forward to eternal life.
They have celebrations
like the day of death. Their day of
death, of course,
it's very fortuitous for them
that it falls on the Reformation Day,
which is the 31st, right?
So they seem to have a lap. Now
originally, of course, that was the time
when
the two
apparently met, the dead and the living
and there was this crossover that was
possible and this great communication.
And
actual fact, it's a very occult day.
But we're not talking about Halloween,
it's just that you said hooligan.
It triggered something.
All right. First Corinthians chapter 13,
for now we see through a glass darkly.
But then face to face, now I know in
part, but then I shall know even as also
I am known.
And now by by this faith
hope
and charity, these three. But the
greatest of these is charity.
This is the one word I don't like the
way that it's been translated.
Charity because it's the word agape
which means this unselfish love
principle.
But
charity, caritas
had been mingled in there and there's a
to me a little bit of a works aspect in
the word charity.
So I don't think it is the best way to
translate it, but we can live with it.
And there abide these three, faith, hope
and charity, but the greatest of these
is charity.
And I would just like to mention that
love will be the abiding one as the
other two will disappear at the second
coming.
Because in Hebrews we read, now faith is
the substance of things hoped for, the
evidence of things not seen.
But when we see face to face, then faith
will have realized its substance because
you're actually seeing it, then you
don't need faith anymore.
And the evidence will be before our
eyes. Martin, why was it so important to
God
that salvation should be by faith?
Well, I think that will prove that you
trust him
in what he says. Because if you learn to
trust what you cannot see
how much more so will you trust what you
can see?
So not being able to see or to see
through a glass darkly
requires faith.
Because that which you cannot see, which
you cannot comprehend maybe
you have to grasp by faith.
So faith
leads to hope.
If you have no faith
then what are you hoping for?
There's nothing to hope for, right?
That's true.
So what are we hoping for?
And why are we hoping for something?
We're hoping for eternal life, we're
hoping for this world to come to an end,
we're hoping for a better world, we're
hoping for many, many things.
And then there is this charity, this
agape
which you have to develop
because without it you will not be able
to be happy in heaven.
It's the same Peter at the same problem.
We all sit with the same problem. Yeah,
and we've been through that many times.
And then he had in his Peter's lady
ladder, the final one was then agape,
right?
So you have to get there.
But in order to get there
you need to have faith and you need to
grasp salvation by faith.
And then you need this hope.
But the greatest of them will be the
only one that remains, the other two
will no longer be found in a dictionary
because
once reality has set in
you do not need faith
and you do not need hope because hope
has been realized.
Okay, so what are we hoping for?
Psalms 31 verse 24, be of good courage
and he shall strengthen your heart, all
ye that hope
in the Lord.
So what are we hoping for, Martin?
We have to Well, it's actually we're
hoping for the Lord to come and fetch us
to have eternal life. Yes, that's your
hope.
So, even if things look very bleak,
that's your hope.
Yeah.
So, your hope always
centers again
on your relationship with Christ and
that he will come and save you. It's
like a child that's waiting for his
parent to come and pick him up. He knows
he'll come.
Psalms 33:18, "Behold, the eye of the
Lord is upon them that fear him, upon
them that hope
in his mercy."
So, hope is a very important thing,
Martin.
If we lose hope,
then what do we look like?
Depressed.
Downtrodden. So, how many people out do
you think are without hope?
I think humanity is
with everything that's happening
these days,
starting to lose hope. Just this week
again, a young girl committed suicide.
And I wrote to the people that informed
me, I said, "Was there nobody that could
give her some hope?"
We need hope, Martin. Without hope,
well, we will drown in this quagmire.
That's the thing. Maybe the question
that you asked, is there nobody?
There is somebody, but nobody brings
them to that to him anymore. That's
Jesus. The only way we can truly get
that real hope. I mean,
sometimes you have a day that everything
just goes wrong. You don't have days
like that, except today, perhaps.
But then you read something like this,
and it you realize where is your hope.
Yes, your hope has to be in the right
place.
Psalms 33:22,
"Let thy mercy, oh Lord, be upon us
according as we hope in thee."
So, is mercy coupled to hope? Yes. So,
does God actually want us to have hope?
The whole time. That's what he why he
put it in the Bible. Do parents want
their children to have hope? Yes. So,
God must want us to have hope, right?
Don't give up hope.
Don't give up.
So, Martin, longing for the advent of
Christ and perseverance in right doing
are prerequisites for eternal life.
Would you agree with that statement?
Yes, definitely.
Okay, does right doing get you to
heaven?
No.
No, faith gets you to heaven. Okay.
If you wish to postpone the second
coming or lose the fire, it is because
you do not really love him. Could you
make a statement like that? Yes.
You could? Mhm.
Martin, then there must be hordes of
people that don't really love him
because they don't want him to come.
Imagine you've just met the love of your
life. Yeah.
And you say, "I don't want you to come."
There's something wrong.
It's
Yeah, you know what? Again, logic.
You cannot hope
and then not long for it. Exactly.
So, modern theology negates the
necessity for the second coming since
the dead meet him at death,
and therefore the second coming is
spiritualized away, but the literal
coming of Christ is, according to the
Bible, the blessed hope, isn't it?
So, all of these things are pretty much
connected.
What is this denomination that you
belong to called?
The Seventh-day
Adventists. All right, there are two
aspects there, right?
Yes. The one refers to the law,
and the other one refers to the second
coming.
And both of them must be in the
equation.
They have to.
You keep the seventh day until the Lord
comes with his advent to take you home.
And just
say that again.
You keep the seventh day holy until the
Lord comes with his second advent to
take you home. All right, is is the
fourth commandment a commandment of
relationship?
Yes.
Completely.
It's the it's absolute relationship. Is
it is it personally
meeting you in a relationship?
You know,
definitely.
So, the thing is,
remember that
quote we had a few episodes back
about the light of the first table and
the second table shining, and then the
fourth commandment shines bright.
There's a reason for it. Yes. The
seventh day
is exactly what you've just said. All
right. Relationship day.
So, that is the day when you have
special time, right?
If you have special time with someone
that you really care about, but you only
have a phone
in order to realize it,
it's it's okay,
but
is it the same as the actual physical
presence? No.
All right, would you say, "Oh, I don't
need the physical presence. I've got the
phone."
Huh?
No. Doesn't work, eh? No.
Okay.
So,
this aspect of life.
John 11:21, "Then said Martha
unto Jesus when her brother had died,
right? Lazarus.
Lord, if thou hadst been here, my
brother had not died.
But I know that even now, whatever thou
wilt ask of God, God will give it to
thee." Jesus said unto her,
"Thy brother shall rise again."
You know, if if the world would just
read the answer now,
they should wake up to some certain
nuances of doctrine, shouldn't they?
Yeah.
Martha said unto him,
"I know that he shall rise again in the
resurrection at the last day." So, when
did she expect him to rise? At the last
day.
And Jesus said unto her, "I am the
resurrection and the life.
He that believeth in me, though he were
dead, yet shall he live.
And whosoever liveth and believeth in me
shall never die. Believest thou this?"
The answer is, did she believe it?
Yes. Absolutely. She believed it, but
she she thought it will come then.
Yes. Now, why did he say Lazarus
sleepeth? Because he's not really dead.
He's just sleeping temporarily.
But he's dead because Jesus said to them
plainly, "Lazarus is dead." But if you
are in Christ, you are just sleeping.
All right. So, we know that there will
be a resurrection. We know that the dead
are not with Christ when they die. They
know nothing.
And therefore,
everything ceases. Faith ceases, hope
ceases, everything ceases.
But that last thought that you die with,
that's a very important thought.
Who do you want to be with, and who do
you know is coming to save you?
All right, let's have a look at what
Paul wrote to Timothy. Second Timothy
chapter 4.
"For I am now ready to be offered, and
the time of my departure is at hand. I
have fought a good fight. I have
finished my course. I have kept the
faith.
Henceforth, there is laid up for me a
crown of righteousness, which the Lord,
the righteous judge, shall give me
at that day.
And not to me only, but unto all them
that love his appearing." So, Martin,
when he says at that day, did he mean
the day when he dies?
No.
No, he was speaking the same as Mar-
Martha. It's exactly the same words,
right?
And he makes sure that he cannot be
misunderstood because he says, "But unto
all them also that
love his appearing."
So, what was Paul's blessed hope?
The resurrection at the second coming.
And and the second coming, right?
And did he love that appearing, that
second coming?
he says it.
So, how important is it that you love
his appearing?
Why does everybody want to put it off?
It's I don't think they have the hope
and faith.
I think if you want to put it off,
the only reason that I think is valid
is to ask for a little more more time
for those who are
lost. But then that must be sincere.
And not be asking it with lip service.
So, actually you're looking for more
time for yourself. But for
us individually,
surely you must love his appearing.
Because you're going to get eternal
life. It says here, basically,
if you love his appearing.
And if you love his appearing, then you
have forsaken your sins.
And you have nothing to hide and nothing
to fear.
Because your sins have gone before you.
In Hebrews 9:28, we read, "So, Christ
was once offered to bear the sins of
many, and unto them that look for him
shall he appear the second time without
sin unto salvation.
Bible is very clear, huh?
Everything happens at the second coming.
Mhm.
But you have to look for him.
You have to love his appearing.
Titus 2:11 onwards, for the grace of God
that bringeth salvation has appeared to
all men,
teaching us that denying ungodliness and
worldly lusts, we should live soberly,
righteously, and godly in this present
world,
looking for that blessed hope and the
glorious glorious appearing of the great
God and our savior,
Jesus Christ.
There you have that
genitive genitive chi construction, the
great God and the savior Jesus Christ
are one in the same.
Mhm.
They are one.
And this blessed hope is clearly the
glorious appearing of the great God and
our savior Jesus Christ. And the looking
is a verb.
So it actually means you are really
looking forward to this. Yes.
Not just paying it lip service.
You have to look forward to it. So
Martin,
if you are not looking forward to it, it
means you're not ready.
Or you don't have the right
relationship.
Isn't that
That's Isn't that axiomatic? Again, we
can come back to the girlfriend or the
If you If you don't want to actually
physically see her, there's a problem.
There's a
problem. There's definitely a problem.
Who gave himself for us that he might
redeem us from all iniquity and purify
unto himself a peculiar people zealous
of good works. So you have this
combination.
But it's all about relationship.
All about relationship and understanding
what Christ is actually doing for you.
So some say the Lord delays his coming.
Luke 12:37, blessed are those servants
whom the Lord, when he cometh, shall
find watching.
Verily I say unto you that he shall gird
himself and make them to sit down to
meet and will come forth and serve them.
You have to be watching.
Watching what? Signs.
That shows you the coming of the Lord is
near.
Okay.
Even at the door. Now, imagine you were
living in the olden days and the
stagecoach was going to come at some
stage
and bring that someone.
Would you be watching for a dust cloud
on the horizon somewhere? Especially
when you're not sure exactly which
hour is coming or which day. Yes, or
whether it's delayed or whatever, right?
Every now and then you'll be looking
You'll be watching. You'll be watching
for the signs. Okay.
And if he shall come in the second watch
or come in the third watch and find them
so,
blessed are those servants.
So this implies patience.
Because you don't know is he coming in
the first, the second, or the third,
right?
And this know that if the goodman of the
house had known what hour the thief
would come, he would have watched
and not have suffered the house to be
broken through.
But ye therefore ready also for the son
of man cometh at an hour when you think
not.
So in other words, here you have a
comparison by contrast.
Mhm.
If you know that thieves are going to
break in,
you'll be watching, right?
How much more so
if you're waiting for the son of man to
come?
Then Peter said unto him, Lord, speakest
thou this parable unto us or even to
all?
And the Lord said, who then is that
faithful and wise steward,
whom his lord shall make ruler of his
household to give them their portion of
meat in due season? Blessed is that
servant whom his lord, when he cometh,
shall find so
doing.
Everything is wrapped up
in this blessed hope
that the culmination of all things is at
hand
and that soon we will be able to go
home.
What a wonderful day that will be.
Did Paul have it? Yes.
Did Peter have it? Yes. Did John have
it?
Mhm.
Why shouldn't we have it?
Did Martin Luther have it?
Yes.
Did the the early Adventists have it?
Absolutely. So like you said, what what
prohibits us from having it? Why is it
seemingly lacking in our time?
What's gone wrong, Martin? I think it's
because we're so close
that the devil is so busy
and he's keeping us busy. He's poured
water onto the fire.
There's another aspect that's very
important, Martin. We We may not
minimize his coming. Mhm.
Knowing this first, that there shall
come in the last days scoffers walking
after their own lusts and saying,
where is the promise of his coming?
Do we find it more and more? Yeah.
Some of the theologians are experts at
it.
Mhm.
Definitely.
Saying to us, no, not not for 100 years.
At least not for 100 years.
For since the fathers fell asleep, all
things continue as they were from the
beginning of the creation. Nothing's
changed. Everything's the same.
I don't know
what planet they're living on, but it's
definitely not the same. Mhm. No, I'm
all the way with you there.
Martin, this is also an interesting
little statement in terms of evolution
because everything continues as it was
from the beginning is uniformitarianism.
And from that you get long ages.
Mhm.
So maybe that's where they get their
long ages from because they've become
uniformitarianists.
Right? It can be. It could be possible.
There's another aspect. So we may not
minimize the coming of Christ. We may
not say, where is this promise of his
coming?
Because these people are called last day
scoffers.
Well, you know,
in Jesus' time and with Paul, they were
already talking. So actually, if you
take it, the last days started already
there.
Now, why was it called the last days?
You know, Martin,
we are living in the last days.
This has caused so much confusion in the
world because the people say, oh, we've
been living in the last days.
Up until the time of Christ,
there was only a promise. Yes.
there was only a type.
Here,
there was an antitype.
Mhm.
There were witnesses to the antitype.
There were very precise witnesses.
If you take
John, Mhm.
This just go, I think it's in Luke,
Martin.
Ah, here we are. We are in Luke. That's
rather nice.
Luke tells us
quite
precisely
what the mission of John was. If you
turn to Luke chapter 1
and we read there
uh
what the mission was. Uh
Now, Zacharias was the father of John
the Baptist
and uh
he disbelieved the angel and so he was
struck dumb.
But uh
when the child was born, they asked what
the name should be
and they chose the name John and the
people were perturbed because this was
not a real family name.
But then he wrote down that it was to be
John and then his his tongue was
loosened.
And then he predicted what the mission
would be.
And he says in verse 71, that we should
be saved from our enemies and from the
hand of all that hate us
to perform the mercy promised to our
fathers and to remember his holy
covenant,
the oath which he sware to our father
Abraham,
that he would grant to us that we, being
delivered out of the hand of our
enemies, may serve him without fear
in holiness and righteousness before him
all the days of our life. And now he
refers to John and he says, and thou,
child,
shall be called the prophet of the
highest.
For thou shalt go before the face of the
Lord to prepare his way
to give knowledge of salvation unto his
people by the remission of sins. Martin
Shouldn't they have known that?
Yes, actually should because everything
in the sacrificial system was already
Showing pointing to this.
But he had to give knowledge of
salvation. So at the end of time when
the anti-typical Elijah comes
then
is it necessary again to give knowledge
of salvation? Well, if you take away the
law, there's no transgression, right?
Where there's no transgression, do you
need a savior? No. No.
So do people need a knowledge of
salvation again in the time that we live
in? Well, can I can can we just jump
back to verse
six? Yes. Just look there about
Zacharias and his wife. Yes. And they
were both righteous before God walking
in all his commandments and ordinances
of the Lord blameless.
So they just
taught their son the same. They taught
their son the same.
Well, Martin, righteousness by faith
can become a very confusing subject.
Otherwise, there would have not been so
many anathemas against that, right?
So he had to give knowledge of salvation
verse 77
through the tender mercy of our God
whereby the day spring from on high has
visited us
to give light to them that sit in
darkness and in the shadow of death to
guide our feet in the way of peace.
That's a very important mission, don't
you think?
And this was the
type. Yeah. And we are now at the
antitype. You know, Martin, if I if I
continue the story, I know I'm going off
topic again because
seems like we constantly do this.
But uh
we read there in chapter two what
happened when the birth of Jesus was
announced to the shepherds, right?
And we read from verse six. And so it
was that while they were there, the days
were accomplished that she should be
delivered. This is Mary now.
And she brought forth her firstborn son
and wrapped him in swaddling clothes and
laid him in a manger
because there was no room for them in
the inn.
Have you mulled that one over? Mhm.
This is the son of God being born.
And there was no room for them in the
inn. Mhm. So Now, the inn is always very
important. One will come to the inn in
this study later as well
because the inn is actually the
hospital, the church. Church. There was
no room for Christ in the church.
He was a square peg in a round hole. He
didn't fit in.
And it was expedient that he should die
for the sake of the nation than that the
nation should die for the sake of him,
right?
Yeah.
So this is all very typological as well
as actual.
So
he was laid in a manger
because
there was no room for him in the inn.
He should have been
in luxury, in kingly environment.
But there was no room for him in this
environment.
And then interestingly, and there were
in the same country shepherds
abiding in the field
keeping watch over their flocks by
night.
Martin, have you ever read that
typologically rather than literally?
Well, it's like watchmen on the wall.
Okay. So there were in the same country.
And why say that?
Why say in the same country?
Or could we say in the same church?
Yes. There was no room for him. No.
If there was none, he was laid in a
manger. There was no room for him.
But
Yes.
in the same church, in the same country
there were shepherds. What are shepherds
supposed to be a type of? Pastors,
right?
Yes.
Abiding
in the field.
Now, in other parables
there were fields. Jesus said there were
treasures hidden in a field. Now, what's
the field?
The word of God, right?
Yeah.
Word of God.
So there were shepherds abiding in the
field.
Martin, there were
people that studied the scriptures.
They were abiding in the field.
And what were they doing?
They were keeping watch. Yes.
Watchmen.
Isn't that interesting?
Tending to the flock.
You know what? You could you could start
reading this
It's amazing. And and
you won't get very far because there's
so much to mull over if you start
reading it typologically, right?
Keeping watch.
For what reason were they keeping watch?
Because they were keeping watch over
their flock.
Yes.
And when did they keep watch by over the
flock?
By night.
Martin
does that typology strike you?
Oh, definitely. It's amazing.
Uh are we living in the night of this
world?
right there. When is Christ going to
come? At what time does the Bible say?
He will come at midnight. Okay. Is it
dark then?
It's the darkest part of the night,
right? He's coming at night.
So Martin, there must be shepherds in
the same country.
What about the others?
There was no room for him. No. Martin,
nothing has changed.
Nothing. Nothing has changed. That just
brings us again back to what we've
started off with. Okay, so we did a side
track, but
that just proves It has to do with it.
It's the last days. It's the last days.
And lo, the angel of the Lord came upon
them and the glory of the Lord shone
around about them and they were sore
afraid. Now, why did the glory shine
around them? Because they were abiding
at night taking care of their flocks.
They were
better equipped
to take the message
than were the learned people
and the prelates.
Because they had no room for him.
They were actually
busy with their father's work.
Well, I was being sidetracked, so let me
put the Bible down again.
And let's read that. So in other words,
Martin, we must not minimize his coming.
And we must persevere.
We must be watching.
And the darker it gets, the more we need
to watch.
Romans 2:7, to them who by patient
continuance in well doing seek for glory
and honor and immortality and eternal
life. There's something to strive for.
But you may not give up halfway. You
must continue.
Ephesians 1:13, in whom you also trusted
after that you have heard the word of
truth, the gospel of your salvation, in
whom also after you believed, you were
sealed with the Holy Spirit of promise.
Yeah, deep words, Martin.
Or 1 John 2:28, now little children
abide in him and when he shall appear
we may have confidence and not be
ashamed before him at his coming. It's a
recurring theme.
And uh if we if we miss the point
we could miss the bus.
And it like you mentioned in the
previous one not at death, at his
coming.
Correct.
In 1 Thessalonians 3:13, we read to the
end he may establish your hearts
unblamable in holiness before God, even
our Father
at the coming of our Lord Jesus Christ
with all his saints. Everything
culminates in that point. It is the
blessed hope.
And there is no way that you can get
around it.
But you have to
be a shepherd. You have to watch by
night.
And you have to take care of the flock.
Who's your brother?
And who is your neighbor?
Everybody that is around you, right?
Exactly. So here's a quote from the
spirit of prophecy. It is the duty of
every believer to fulfill faithfully his
by baptismal vows.
If earnest perseverance and diligence
are needed in order to attain success in
temporal matters, how much more
important that we make earnest efforts
to obtain the heavenly treasure?
So Martin, we need to encourage each
other.
We need not be distracted by those who
have no room
for the second coming. True.
Don't let they
steal from you your blessed hope.
John 8:13, the Pharisees therefore said
unto him, "Thou bearest record of
thyself, thy record is not true."
John 15:9, "As the Father has loved me,
so I have loved you. Continue in my
love." So, you have this constant
contrast.
You have the unbelievers,
and then you have those that
continue and persevere.
Romans 11:22, "Behold, therefore, the
goodness and severity of God. On them
which fell, severity, but towards thee,
goodness."
"If thou continue in his goodness,
otherwise thou also shalt be cut off."
So, how important is perseverance?
Life and death.
Goodness and severity of God.
It's amazing how many people only see
the severity of God, his wrath,
with the second coming.
But it's actually his goodness because
he's coming to take
on what side of the fence you're
standing.
That's it.
All right, there'll be two sides. The
one will say, "Rocks fall on us. Hide us
from the face of the one who comes with
the clouds, right?" And the other lot
will say, "This is our God on whom we
have waited. He will save us."
So, verse 24, 1 John
chapter 2, "Let there therefore abide in
you which you have heard from the
beginning. If that which we have heard
from the beginning shall remain in you,
you also shall continue in the Son and
in the Father." Once you know the truth,
don't let yourself be sidetracked. Don't
let someone rob you, as you just said,
of the blessed hope.
Because
if they have robbed you of the blessed
hope, you have nothing left.
Nothing. Nothing.
So, here's this young man who called
Jesus good master.
"And behold, one came and said unto him,
'Good master, what good thing shall I do
that I may have eternal life?'"
How many people ask that these days?
Many, right?
Many. Many.
"And he said unto them, 'Why callest
thou me good? There is none good but
one,
that is God.'"
Martin, is it possible that this young
man knew that he was dealing with God
himself?
I think so, yes. And therefore he called
him good master.
And Jesus sort of highlighted it by
saying, "Why callest thou me good?
There's none good but one, and that is
God." Are you saying, young man,
that you realize that you are speaking
to God?
"But if thou wilt enter into life,
keep the commandments."
Has the Lord in the meantime decided
that that is obsolete?
It's so plain. And the thing is now you
try Most people try and get around this,
"Oh, but he's not he's speaking about
the 10 Commandments here." Excuse me.
Oh.
Okay, then why does he list them?
Exactly. Oh, but then they get to the
point, "Yeah, but he's not mentioning
all of them." You know, if you want to
get out of it, you will think up excuse.
Okay, he said unto him, "Which?"
Jesus said,
"Thou shalt do no murder. Thou shalt not
commit adultery. Thou shalt not steal.
Thou shalt not bear false witness. Honor
thy father and thy mother. Thou shalt
love thy neighbor as thyself." So, here
he lists the second table.
Uh-huh.
And he sums it up by saying, "This is
love your neighbor." Martin, why did he
not list the first one? You say he left
out half. Why did he not list the first
one? Because he knew that was the part
that was missing with the young That was
his problem, right?
So,
this rich young ruler was quite happy
to share some of his riches with his
neighbor.
Mhm.
But he wasn't prepared to share it all
with God.
Isn't it amazing? We are back at that
part where if you
don't adhere to the first table,
the second table
is null and void.
It doesn't matter if you are looking out
for your brother, you're doing
everything right, but you've lost your
You cannot get the power if you haven't
got
the first The light The light that you
bring to them are in the first table.
That's why I said, "This young man said
unto him, 'All these things have kept
from my youth up. What lack I yet?'"
Well, what didn't he mention?
It was love God.
Relationship. All right, Jesus said unto
him, "If thou wilt be perfect,
go and sell that thou hast and give to
the poor, and thou shalt have treasure
in heaven, and come and follow me."
Martin, he's speaking like the Pope
there, right?
Isn't that what the Pope says?
Yeah. Go and sell everything you have
and go and live in a monastery and
shut yourself away. Yeah, and these
buddies, the World Economic Forum's got
it the same. You'll own nothing and
you'll be happy. All right, so Jesus
said,
"Go and get rid of everything that you
have and come and follow me."
That was That was a price too high to
pay.
But I think it was
a very
spiritual thing
All right. Now, once you do that,
once you lay it all on the altar and I'm
all prepared to lose it all,
isn't it amazing that God sometimes
turns it around?
Oh, yes. Do you really lose it all, or
do you gain it all? Gain all. You gain
it all, right?
Definitely. Even if you lose it all in
terms of the monetary aspect, you will
still gain it all.
All right?
That's it.
You'll get gain the true riches.
Isn't that why God also said, "Seek ye
first the kingdom,
Yes.
and all these things will be added"?
Now, there were many that were rich in
the days when Jesus was on this earth.
Nicodemus was a rich man.
He basically funded the the fledgling
church.
So, he used his riches wisely.
But this young ruler was not prepared to
give everything to the poor. Now, who
are the poor, Martin?
Poor in spirit. The poor in spirit,
those who are in need of salvation.
"But when the young man heard that
saying, he went away sorrowful, for he
had great possessions." He was
short-sighted.
"Then said Jesus unto his disciples,
'Verily, I say unto you, that a rich man
shall hardly enter into the kingdom of
heaven.
And again I say unto you, it is easier
for a camel to go through the eye of a
needle than for a rich man to enter into
the kingdom of God.'"
"And when his disciples heard it, they
were exceedingly amazed, saying,
'Who can then be saved?'" Now, it's
interesting that in the mindset at that
time, if you were rich,
you were blessed of God.
That's amazing. Therefore,
it was proof that you were
part of the kingdom.
And here Jesus goes and he turns it
around.
Is there anything wrong with having
money? No. No.
It's the love of money that's the
problem, not money.
So, don't trust those new translations
that leave the love of out of that
sentence.
"But then Jesus, beholding them, said
unto them, 'With men, this is
impossible, but with God, all things are
possible.'" So, the problem is not
money, it's the love of money that's the
problem. It's when you put that above
the relationship you have with God. Yes.
What did he say to Zacchaeus?
He said he must pay back everything that
he stole.
Yes, and what did Zacchaeus do? He did
exactly that. He said, "If I have
wronged anyone, I will repay,
and I will multiply what I have repaid."
But he didn't tell him to quit his job.
No.
Neither did John the Baptist
tell those that came to him that they
had to quit.
He said, "Be satisfied."
"And when he was gone forth on to his
way,
there came one running and kneeled to
him and asked him, 'Good master, what
shall I do that I may inherit eternal
life?'" This is the story now, the same
story in the Gospel of Mark.
We just read it in Matthew.
"And Jesus said unto him, 'Why thou me
good? There's none good but one, that is
God."
All right, Martin, so here in the story,
as we read it in Mark, there is a little
bit of additional information.
You read here, he came running
and he kneeled
to him.
So, is there merit in the thought that
he knew that he was dealing not with an
ordinary man?
Yes. Yes. Okay.
The rest of the story here is the same,
but it has another twist.
Cuz Jesus says, "Thou knowest the
commandments. Do not commit adultery, do
not kill, do not steal, do not bear
false witness, defraud not, honor thy
father and thy mother."
And he answered and said to him,
"Master, all these I have observed from
my youth." And Jesus beholding him
loved him.
That's another addition.
So, we have two things. He kneeled
Yeah.
and it says Jesus loved him.
And said unto him, "One thing thou
lackest."
Now,
love your neighbor
and love God.
Yes.
All right. So, what is God asking for?
He's asking for reciprocity.
God loves you.
Therefore, you should love God.
Yeah.
Now, in your relationship,
do you have a relationship if one loves
and the other one does not?
No.
Oh. No, that won't fit. It has to be
reciprocal. Reciprocal, definitely.
Right? Otherwise, it's it's not going to
work. It's going to be useless, right?
So, Martin, is it unreasonable
for God to say, "You must love me"? No.
Not at all.
Because he loves you. Isn't it a
marriage relationship?
Yes. All right. So, if it's a marriage,
must be reciprocal.
So, God is not unreasonable.
Satan says he's unreasonable.
Mhm.
But he's not unreasonable because that's
the nature of love.
Yes. But Satan says that because he's
interpreting it, he demands you love
him.
But he forgets to put in the part that
God loved you first. Aha.
Okay.
While we were yet sinners, God died for
us. So, he must love us.
For cause greater love has no one than
he who lays down his life,
right? Yeah.
For a friend.
So, these little interesting nuances
that are added in here just
bring the story alive.
"Go thy way, sell whatever thou hast and
give to the poor, and thou shalt have
treasure in heaven, and come take up the
cross and follow me."
I think that last part is what really
got to him. Would he have had any lack
if he had followed? Nothing. Have you
had lack since you followed?
No. Have I had lack since I followed?
No.
You see, but your eyes opened.
Because if you sometimes look in a
worldly view, some people will say, "No,
but we did lose."
Because their eyes are not open to have
the blessed hope
in seeing that fulfillment of
um having everything that you need.
My wife just finished writing the book
on our experiences or some of our
experiences.
And uh
when we read it again,
we were absolutely amazed
at how God has led throughout all of
these years.
And to think where we came from and
where we are now,
and what happened to those that didn't
budge, that didn't move.
Am I worse off or better off?
We have to ask ourselves these questions
even if times are tough. That's it. Are
we worse off or better off?
Well, there's another story. A certain
lawyer
came to him and said, "Behold, a certain
lawyer stood up and tempted him saying,
'Master, what shall I do to have
inherited eternal life?'"
And again, it's from the Gospel of Luke.
And he said unto him, "What is written
in the law?
How readest thou?" Isn't it interesting
that in both cases, he talks about the
law Definitely.
and the commandments?
And he answering said, "Thou shalt love
the Lord thy God with all thy heart and
with all thy soul and with all thy
strength and with all thy mind and thy
neighbor as thyself." So, this lawyer
had both
tables.
He got that bit right, right?
And he said to him, "Thou'st answered
right. This do, and thou shalt live."
Yeah.
But he, willing to justify himself, said
unto Jesus, Mhm. "Who is my neighbor?"
Now, that's typical. Now, would he have
asked that question even if he was
really keeping the first table?
No, he wouldn't have. No, he wouldn't
have, but he did. He asked it.
Now, the Jews, did they consider
themselves the elect?
Exactly. Mhm. How many religious systems
have election?
All of them. All right. Protestant
denominations as well? All right.
And Jesus answering said,
and he tells the story.
And the story completely blasts this
young lawyer out of the water, right?
Now, we've read it many times, but let's
go through it because this is what it
entails to be part
of the people that are waiting and
watching for the coming of the Lord.
A certain man,
that's generic.
It's very generic. A certain man. Could
be anyone, right?
Went down from Jerusalem to Jericho.
Now, Jericho was a cursed city.
Jerusalem
was the city of salvation, right?
You can't go up to Jericho, you can only
go down.
And he fell amongst thieves, which
stripped him of his raiment, wounded
him, departed leaving him half dead.
Now, if we had to read this story
typologically,
then we're saying humanity, generically,
has departed from the Jerusalem
principle and is heading towards the
Jericho principle. And if you do that,
you will fall amongst thieves,
and they will strip you of your robe of
righteousness. In other words, the
demons will get hold of you, and they
will wound you, and they will leave you
half dead. Yeah.
And by chance,
there came a certain priest that way,
and when he saw him, he passed by on the
other side. So, who is he talking about?
The Pharisees. All right. So, here were
these people that thought
they were the elect of God, they were
saved. This miserable specimen over
there,
he was obviously not worthy. God never
protected him.
And so, he walked by on the other side.
And then a Levite came.
And when he was at the place, came,
looked on him, and passed by on the
other side. This this is stunning.
The other one, he just passed by. This
one had a look.
He even had a look at this miserable
specimen.
And he decided, "Not worth it."
And he walked on.
Martin,
if
sin-struck people
are the problem,
how many people say,
"Don't deal with that one.
Don't get involved or try to help this
one or
that one with his weird hairstyle and
five nose rings or whatever."
Uh have a look at that and pass by on
the other side. Does it happen today?
But a certain Samaritan, now that was a
swear word.
Apparently, this story actually took
place.
And Jesus used it in a spiritual format,
then.
So, here was a Samaritan, very much
despised by these people as he
journeyed. Now, Martin, this is
interesting because this Samaritan
didn't come down from Jerusalem.
He wasn't on his way to Jericho.
He journeyed. Yeah.
He came where he was.
That's fascinating.
Do you sometimes meet people where they
are?
Yes. Okay. Supposed to.
And when he saw him, he had
compassion on him.
And he went to him and bound up his
wounds, pouring in oil and wine, and set
him on his own beast, and brought him to
an inn, and took care of him. Now, we've
spoken about an inn before, right?
This was a very special inn because it
was a hospital.
And on the morrow when he departed, he
took out two pence and gave them to the
host and said unto him,
"Take care of him, and whatsoever thou
spendest more, when I come again, I will
repay thee." That should give you a clue
who this despised one, for whom there
was no room,
really was.
It was a Samaritan.
Because the Jews called Jesus, "Thou art
a Samaritan. Thou hast the demon."
They hated
what he stood for.
His church didn't have place for him.
There was no room. There was no room. He
had to be laid in a manger. Okay, but
fortunately, there were some shepherds
out in the field that did take care of
the flock.
So, Martin, this Samaritan is a type of
Christ, despised, rejected by men.
But he was on a journey
to come where we are,
to meet us
in our need.
And then he poured out something very
interesting, oil and wine.
Oil is the Holy Spirit. Wine is the
doctrine.
He set him on his own beast. He carried
him.
His own beast. It's also a symbol of the
church, the true shepherds.
Because he takes him to an inn. He takes
him to the church.
And took care of him. He himself took
care of him.
And then on the morrow when he departed,
he took out
two pence.
Now, pence was a day's wages.
So, he gave two days wages.
And gave them to the host and said unto
him, "Take care of him.
And whatsoever thou spendest more, when
I come again,
I will repay thee."
"Which now of these three thinkest thou
was neighbor unto him that fell amongst
the thieves?" And he said, "He that
showed mercy on him."
He didn't want to say the Samaritan.
So, he sort of Yeah. Uh
moved around it. Then said Jesus unto
him, "Go and do thou likewise."
So, that's a very, very important
lesson. There's another lesson in here.
He gave him two pence. That's two days
wages.
Martin, if we think in terms of the
cosmic week,
Mhm.
where a day is a thousand years, then
two days wages would be two cosmic days.
That would be 2,000 years.
Martin,
I dare not go further, right? We'd get
into trouble, right?
Yeah, well, maybe
the good Samaritan will
not in too distant future come and pay
what they
at the inn did more. Uh-huh, what the
innkeeper did more. Well, Martin, it's
just an interesting thought. Uh some of
our early pioneers Mhm. believed that
the two pence were a reference to a time
frame
of 6,000 years. Because Jesus came
at 4,000 Mhm. plus the 2,000.
And when he comes, he will repay those
that actually did the work they should
be doing at the inn, taking care of the
wounded and the bruised and the sick,
not walking by on the other side. Here's
another indication that I don't think
we're too far off
Mhm. in terms of the time frame.
Now,
let's just unpack this Jericho a little
bit.
Jeremiah 6:26, "O daughter of my people,
gird thee with sackcloth and wallow
thyself in ashes.
Make thee mourning as for an only son,
most bitter lamentation for the spoiler
shall suddenly come upon us."
1 Kings 16:34,
"In his days did Hiel the Bethelite
build Jericho.
He laid the foundation thereof with
Abiram his firstborn, and set up the
gates thereof with his younger son
Segub, according to the word of the Lord
which he spoke by Joshua the son of
Nun." That city was never to be rebuilt.
Yeah.
We should never go down to Jericho.
But they rebuilt it.
And it cost him his firstborn, and it
cost him his younger son.
So, a high price to pay.
You can lose a lot, Martin,
if you try to rebuild Jericho.
Yeah. Yeah. If And we have the same
lamentation to do. We have to mourn as
for an only son.
For the spoiler shall suddenly come upon
us. We need to be prepared.
Now, Jesus was despised, as we know.
It says in Isaiah that he was despised
and rejected of men. There was no room
for him.
A man of sorrows, acquainted with grief.
We hid, as it were, our faces from him.
He was despised,
and we esteemed him not.
That sentence in John, "He came unto his
own,
and his own received him not."
John 8:47, "He that is of God heareth
God's word. Ye therefore hear them not,
because ye are not of God."
Then answered the Jews and said unto
him,
"Say we not well that thou art a
Samaritan and hast the devil?"
Can you see the relationship there? So,
was Jesus referring to himself when he
told the story?
Yep.
Jesus said that his burden is light.
"For my yoke is easy and my burden is
light." Is it therefore a difficult
thing that he asks of us? No. Go and do
likewise. And he will do the good thing
in you, if you let him.
Okay. So, what is our task, Martin,
while we wait
for the coming of the Lord?
What did the shepherds do?
They watched. Yes. Keeping the flock at
night. At night.
Okay.
What's the second thing we must do? Uh
we should seek the lost.
Okay. We should go and bind up the
wounds of the brokenhearted. We should
we bring them to the church.
What about the Levite
and the priest in the church?
They'll walk by.
We'll have them in the church, right?
That's it.
We should also treat
them as the one that we were looking
after
that were lying next to the road. So, we
must also pray for them and help them.
Mhm.
Now, people write to me a lot, Martin,
and they say this and that and the other
was just said in a sermon. Mhm.
What should I do about it?
I say, "Pray for the man."
The man needs prayer.
"But he's a pastor in the church."
Well, then he needs more prayer.
Exactly.
You know, often I can say where he was
educated, what he did, etc. But let's
not go there.
It's amazing. And And you know who
writes?
Young,
on fire,
new converts. Yeah.
They can see when something is seriously
amiss,
and when someone doesn't want the Lord
to come
Yeah. again.
So, we have to look at the mission of
Jesus. The spirit of the Lord God is
upon me, because the Lord has anointed
me to preach good tidings unto the meek.
So, that's our job, right? That's it.
He has sent me to bind up the
brokenhearted.
That same that's lying next to the road.
Okay.
To proclaim liberty to the captives,
and the opening of the prison to them
that are bound. In other words, to
preach the gospel to the unconverted.
Will you be loved, or will you be
treated like a Samaritan?
Yep, you'll be hated.
Okay.
To proclaim the acceptable year of the
Lord and the day of vengeance of our God
to comfort all that mourn. Is there a
day when Christ will come? Yes.
All right. So, you have to proclaim the
acceptable year of the Lord. Now's the
time of salvation. Mhm.
But you also have to preach the second
coming of Christ.
To whom?
To comfort all that mourn.
To appoint unto them that mourn in Zion,
and to give them beauty for ashes,
oil of joy for mourning, the garment of
praise for the spirit of heaviness,
that they might be called trees of
righteousness, the planting of the Lord,
that he might be glorified. This was
Christ's work. Yeah.
Why did that young girl commit suicide?
Because she was never
educated
in beauty for ashes,
joy for mourning, and a garment of
praise for a spirit of heaviness.
Isn't it a sad world we're living in?
a terrible.
This is a continuous trend in the world
today. We've lost
all of this. That's why the world is in
the state that it is.
Isn't it time that God's people rallied
around this call?
Isaiah 42:6, "And I the Lord have called
thee in righteousness. I will hold thine
hand, I will keep thee, and give thee
for a covenant of the people for a light
of the Gentiles to open the blind eyes,
to bring out the prisoners from prison,
and them that sit in darkness out of the
prison house.
Constantly you have this theme.
We have evangelism to do.
We cannot we dare not be like the priest
and the Levite.
We have to meet the people where they
are.
We mustn't run away from those that are
bleeding. We should bind them up and
bring them to the inn. Yeah.
And by the way,
those wages
they are more or less used now.
Mhm. That's it. The two pence are gone.
It's They're gone. Okay.
You are with this says Isaiah 43, says
the Lord, and my servant whom I have
chosen that you may know and believe me
and understand that I am he. Before me
there was no God formed, neither shall
there be after me. So, what's important
here? You are to be a witness.
You are to be a servant to do what? To
know and believe him.
To show who he is, that he is God. I,
even I am the Lord, and besides me there
is no savior.
Martin,
how does this fit into interreligious
relationships?
You cannot compromise.
You have to lead people to the one who
can save. There is no other savior. So,
the what
gain can you have in trying to
do this ecumenical work? All right.
Let's just take a step back. I've been
thinking about this lately. Mhm.
Ecumenism.
Why is it necessary in the eyes of the
world to have ecumenism?
Mhm.
Isn't it to reach a compromise position
where we can all live safely next to
each other?
Yes. Right? That's what they're aiming
for, yes.
All right. The fact that you need
ecumenism
doesn't that automatically imply that
you are excluding truth? Yes.
Because you wouldn't need ecumenism, you
would just have one truth. That's it.
So, as soon as you need ecumenism, you
are propagating a lie.
Yeah, true. Because then even the people
that are in that ecumenism
they are denying something. They are
compromising on something
Yes. in order to accommodate someone who
doesn't want to accept whatever that is.
Therefore, ecumenism cannot be from God,
period.
Yeah.
Because it is an unwillingness
to sacrifice
for the sake of truth.
The more you think about it,
the more you have to start realizing God
cannot be inside an of an ecumenical
council.
You cannot compromise on truth.
No. There's only one truth. There's only
one savior.
And there's only one way to salvation.
You cannot have salvation by works
compromising with salvation by faith.
Mhm. Therefore, you cannot have a joint
declaration on justification that
includes works. Because works has
nothing to do with justification.
You Works are a consequence and they are
sanctification.
So, the whole issue of compromise
is
impossible to reconcile with truth.
Yeah.
Ephesians tells us in chapter 3 from
verse 9, and to make all men see what is
the fellowship of the mystery which from
the beginning of the world has been hid
in God who created all things by Jesus
Christ to the intent that now unto the
principalities and powers in heavenly
places might be known by the church
the manifold wisdom of God according to
the eternal purpose which he purposed in
Christ Jesus our Lord, in whom we have
boldness and access with confidence by
the faith of him. The task of the church
is to preach the message of salvation
and to bring hope to the world and there
is only one way in which this can be
achieved. No compromise can be made with
this. And that is so important because
in ecumenism
you think that you're going to have hope
and blessings. No.
But that is the falsehood, the false
hope. Yes, you you are covering up. You
are covering up and you are compromising
on issues that are essential to
salvation.
In John chapter 6, we read then Simon
Peter answered and said, Lord, to whom
shall we go? Thou hast the word of
eternal life. If you do not eat the
flesh of the Son of God and drink his
blood, you have no part in him. And they
all left.
Do you also want to go? Jesus said.
Where can we go? Peter answered and
said, To whom shall we go?
Thou hast the words of eternal life.
Isn't this what should be told to an
ecumenical council and to an
interreligious relationship?
If you do not accept that you have to
eat the flesh and drink the blood of the
Son of God to internalize him
you have no part in him.
And if they all turn away, then?
Maybe Peter will remain and say, Where
shall I go? You have the words of
eternal life.
That whatsoever John 3:15, that
whosoever believeth in him should not
perish, but have eternal life.
Whoso eateth my flesh and drinketh my
blood hath eternal life, and I will
raise him up at the last day.
Always comes back to that day, right?
Yeah.
The blessed hope. So,
how can you bring hope if you're not
talking about that day? Correct. And
John 17 verse 3, And this is life
eternal that they may know thee, the
only true God, and Jesus Christ whom
thou has sent. Martin, it is so clear.
Our gospel commission is so
straightforward
that there cannot be another or another
nuance. It's either this or nothing.
So, we've read this verse in Romans
before that you have to have patient
continuance
in doing these things.
And 1 John 5:11 says, And this is the
record that God has given to us eternal
life, and this life is in his Son.
And whatever we ask, we receive of him
because we keep his commandments and do
the things that are pleasing to him. Can
you Can you divorce any one of these
aspects?
No.
And that's why again can have a broken
record, but that's why you cannot
substitute or compromise on any of this.
You cannot compromise on it. This is the
way it is.
And the plan of salvation says we are
transgressors.
We have no hope unless we have a savior.
Mhm.
And that savior is Jesus Christ, and
Jesus Christ
can impute and impart his righteousness
to us, of which we have no part. Mhm.
So that we may have his life and his
righteousness in which we have no part.
This is This is an amazing gospel of
salvation. There is no other. No.
And we have to keep the commandments
because we have to come back into
harmony with God. Not to be saved, but
because we are saved.
That's it.
1 Timothy 6:11, But thou, oh man of God,
flee these things and follow after
righteousness, godliness, faith, love,
patience, meekness.
Fight the good fight of faith. Lo, lay
hold on eternal life whereunto thou art
also called and has professed a good
profession before many witnesses.
I give thee charge in the sight of God
who quickeneth all things, and before
Christ Jesus, who before Pontius Pilate
witnessed the good confession.
That thou keep this commandment without
spot unreprovable until the appearing of
our Lord Jesus Christ. Martin, that's
the crux of the matter. Mhm.
There's no compromise possible. This is
the way it is.
And that's the way it's going to stay
until the end.
This is our marching order. This is our
job. And our hope. Yes.
And it will culminate in the second
coming of Christ.
So, Martin, if we do these things
then we can say with all the rest of the
saints This is our God.
Yeah. We have waited for him, and he
will
save us. Let's pray.
Amen.
Heavenly Father,
we are living in this dramatic time
when these events will take place.
And we are in that generation
that will see these things if we remain
faithful.
Help your people not to give up now, but
to redouble their efforts.
And let us stand firm in the blessed
hope, the second coming of Jesus Christ.
Is my prayer in Jesus name. Amen. Amen.